the bunny back in the box so you want to
make a Nicholas Cage film well you came
to the right place it's not easy to be
an Academy Award winner become a meme
and simultaneously be loved and hated
and still continue to work but as long
as you are wild at heart and don't mind
facing off against more talented actors
I am confident that you two could find
yourself in the City of Angels first off
make sure you star and critically
acclaimed films where you will be
recognized for your achievements of
course these are only a way for you to
get your name big enough so you can get
into the real moneymakers I've been
stuck in an urn for the last ten years
so get back there and dig the play now
you're welcome
Bobby's down on us but it's my sewer
jiminy and I love it
I'd follow you into a snarling package
government as a member of the Coppola
family you have a rich history of
artists and talent that you can pull
from
dad or not your most valuable asset as
an actor is your hair it is able to
communicate things about your character
that your words and emotions never could
it is an incredibly powerful tool with
stupendous diversity that should be
pushed to its limits
trade routes now you must make a mark on
your film and what better way to do that
than a good old-fashioned freak out
step away from the bike ha splat touch
it how'd it get burned
how'd it get burned I get burned what's
what a lot I'll be arrested put in
Airport Jail
just get your ticket in move on okay get
your goddamn ticket hello hard I didn't
miss anything
time have you ever been dragged to the
sidewalk and beat until you pissed and
blood I am catch I have to go see my
kids
you put advice from I go have to see
like it's a tie on me man
I lost my hand I lost my bride joy yes
his hair Johnny as his bride you want me
to take my heartbreak
put it away forget our dad about John oh
yes that's right kid
you did it you hit the mother love you
saw me start for a million with your own
eyes I love you ever think about your
kids your grandkids huh
sucking up their inheritance you that
oxygen tube and finish intensive care I
hate you hey b c d e f g h i j k l my ba
make sure to focus on your Nouveau
shamanic training to guide your actions
I would paint my face and sort of like
an afro-caribbean voodoo icon or New
Orleanian voodoo icon baron sammedi I
put black contacts in my eyes I would
put bits of rock that was that had a
frequency to it or allegedly had a
frequency to it I would I would so
Egyptian artifacts into my costume and I
wouldn't talk to anybody of course it
doesn't hurt to be able to pull from a
real-life experience was making man
fudgesicle people say that the eyes are
the window to the soul and you want the
audience to feel your emotions as if
they were their very own open up those
soul windows all the way I couldn't
think of a more horrible job if I wanted
to and you have to do it and finally you
know what's funny pretty much everything
and that's it follow these simple
instructions and you'll be on your way
to making your very own Nicolas Cage
film